Yeah.
Hmm hmm.
Sorry.
I was just drinking a jar of my own.
Nevermind.
Welcome to reckless.
This agreement.
The only show on the Internet you can trust.
I'm your host,
a timid megalomaniac.
And the last time you watched star wars,
did you find yourself wondering where the rebel's got the plans are that star?
If so,
here's your answer.
Or if you prefer an over complicated version.
All right,
look,
I've never made a prequal.
In fact,
I've never made a movie at all and probably shouldn't be so smug when I'm making
fun of them.
But I've got some opinions about rogue one.
The main stream media would have you believe that it's just a good movie about
some star wars.
But I found a copy under some boxes while I was digging around for food last
week and I watched it.
And folks,
it is so much more than that.
Rogue one is an attack on everything you hold dear,
because it makes all the things that happened in star wars.
Ridiculous.
The good guys become bad,
the bad guys become stupid and the plot becomes pointless.
Everything just topsy turvy to hell and back.
So let me finish this and we'll get right to it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's definitely better if I let it cool down.
Princess Leia is an action hero who accidentally found herself in a damsel in
distress situation and was immediately like somebody has to say my skins,
and she compared Darth Vader to a naughty puppy talk.
I should have expected to find you holding Vader's leash or an abused child.
And most impressively and her very first scene,
she keeps her wits about her in a stressful situation,
improvising a clever line to keep the death star plans safe from Vader's
aggressive.
Just stipulations.
I'm a member of the imperial Senate on a diplomatic mission to Alderaan pod or
the rebel line and to trade at least that seems clever.
In 1977 when rogue one came out,
it revealed that lay was trying to get away with her imperial Senate line five
minutes after a gritty and action packed laser light show.
She was just on the front lines of the very first battle of a star war and now
she's all,
well,
that wasn't me.
Vader,
sorry.
Get the plans.
What we thought was a bad ass to finance becomes with this context as pathetic
and unconvincing as a panic.
15 year old insisting that the pack of American spirits in her jacket is totally
Jessica's.
Or like someone saying to the cops,
seriously,
I suffer.
Right.
Has it been in Jinxing as her overturn Camaro explodes behind her also,
this is different thing.
They don't know that she has the plans and as a trader.
So why did she is blop her shit?
Why did Bader just blow up or shit,
why didn't Vader,
you know what,
nevermind.
Rogue one is not kind to delay his legacy and I'm talking about more than just
that creepy CGI face.
I'm talking about this and analysis of the plans provided by Princess Leia.
Oh,
they were obtained the by Princess Layo.
Were they?
What was her contribution again?
The transmission we received.
Oh,
so like a five minute walk.
Cool.
I understand she's important and I'm not trying to cut down Leah,
but how come nobody ever mentions the spy who built the fatal flaw into that
store in the first place
have placed a weakness deep and within the system of flow,
so small and powerful and then we'll never find it.
Or that spies daughter Jen who sacrificed her life to steal those plants or her
buddy Cassie and who's been casually,
often civilians and the name of the rebellions since childhood apparently have
been in this fight since I was six years old.
I think maybe they deserve some credit.
Oh,
and then there was that blind guy with a stick and this guy,
he was like brave.
Then there's all the people who died in the giant battle lay is the most famous
and least important member of a huge team,
but she gets all the credit like the rebellion Stan Lee and wait,
if the rebellion has been going on since Caspian was six how come they've only
now managed to gather their forces?
We've only now managed to gather our forces.
It seems like the rebellion kind of blows were on at the bit.
First let's talk about
grand loft.
Talking like less spends most of his star war casually throwing shade at an
eight foot tall robot space wizard.
What I'm taking an all for risk data,
better work.
What a boss,
right?
It turns out he's just some guy taking credit from director Krennic who actually
designed and built the death star.
I will tell him that I will be taking control over the weapon I first spoke of
years ago.
Effective immediately
we stand.
Yeah,
I'm mixed.
Meyer,
chief chronics sort of a whiner but it's also hard to be intimidated by target
and now that I know he's just one of the bobs from office space that shouting
nerd was overseeing the project from the beginning and even personally recruited
the people who made the weapon possible.
No,
I don't.
Space Office politics is like not the most interesting thing to be talking about
in this video,
but this is the second time ro one has gone out of its way to let us know that a
character we once thought was cool isn't actually cool.
The empire is run by a bunch of screening suits and not the scary kind of
scheming,
the annoying kind of scheming that makes you one popular.
This last shot is very different.
If the empire is just Dilbert Catbert,
we're just incinerated and had the remains hurled at the bic void of space.
I don't know.
It bugs me.
Remember Admiral Marty,
he's the guy who was talking up the death star in this scene saying this station
is now the ultimate power in the universe.
I suggest we use it and invaders like Dorothy too proud on
the [inaudible].
This is just Bain.
I'm just doing vein is insignificant tax to the power before,
which is a bit like interrupting a shareholders' meeting to say marketing did a
great job,
but the real hero here was Jesus.
But anyway,
modest reply is don't try to frighten us with your sorcerers ways.
Lord Vader,
your sad devotion to that ancient religion has not hoped you conjure up the
store in data tapes.
Oh,
given you clairvoyants enough to find the rebels.
Hidden fault.
Okay,
I'm sorry.
And went down the wrong hole.
A bad moment for a sip in retrospect point is joking people is Vader's signature
management technique.
Mati seems like kind of a dummy before rogue one even came out,
but now we also know that not only with this going on
so was this.
There's also no way he thinks his devotion to the forces sad when it gives you
the ability to waste a hallway full of dudes and 28 seconds flat.
Yeah,
I timed it.
What?
It's possible that this is [inaudible] first day and he decided to make an
impression as a tough guy by insulting the only guy in the room was allowed to
wear a cape to the meeting.
But that just seems like a bad idea.
We have not yet met a competent member of the empire,
so how come the rebellion doesn't just steamroll them?
Well,
I'm glad you asked that Straw man voice in my head because polio,
shucks.
If I got an answer for you
now that we're near the end of my video,
let me finally actually explain the plot of rogue one first.
The rebellion recruits Jen Rza who investigate the death star.
He's claiming the emperor is creating a weapon,
the power to destroy the entire planet,
but when she brings back a report,
they're split between not believing her daughters who's known reason.
When my father have to lie,
what benefit would it bring him to lear our forces into a final battle to
destroy us once and for all?
Everything based on what the testimony of the criminal and thinking,
they should just surrender.
If the empire has this kind of power,
what chance do we have?
What chance do we have?
There is no hope
is finished.
In the end,
they compromise and say that they don't believe her and they're going to
surrender.
I'm sorry,
without the full support of the council,
the author to grade,
they prefer to surrender or why center in the first place.
If you're not going to believe her,
you might ask or maybe that's stupid,
but I'm not done.
After that meeting,
gin and her buddies defy the rebellion and go to steal the death star plans.
Anyway.
Then the rebellion finds out and launches an attack which makes the empire put
up their shields,
trapping our heroes on the planet.
To explode and die.
So to recap,
gene or so and her buddies singlehandedly saved the rebellion and exchange that
got screwed over by bureaucracy and written out of history.
So all the credit for their accomplishments was given to a smuggler,
a farm boy,
a princess,
and a monkey,
which is a pretty good name for a folk song.
And now we've reached what this means.
Okay.
Disney and Gareth Edwards or trying to ruin star wars.
Why?
I don't know,
to make room for more marvel movies to turn us all into Communist.
Probably that one,
whatever the case we have to do whatever it takes to stop them.
And by we I'm mean you because like this is sort of embarrassing but the door to
this bunker on the open from the outside and I'm not getting it.
Cell reception down here and I'm quickly running out of food and how long ago
ran out of fresh water.
So if anybody wants to call the head of cracked or even just come by and
no,
never mind,
don't worry about it.
I got,
I got this covered.
I'll be fine.
No worries.
Thanks for watching.
That's a farm boy.
I blew a monkey around and adventure
was that old fashioned blaster,
the Millennium Falcon and the boy's dad.
His Saber line.
Thanks for watching reckless disagreement.
If you want to see more videos like this,
click on another correct video.
If you want.
I subscribe it,
the big C,
if you,
once you get notified,
next time we do a video,
click on the bill and,
uh,
Viva la resistance.
My friends.